okay for people who are joining this
live stream we are looking at some new
machine learning functionality in one
language intended I hope for the next
version and let's see a tenon I think
you're going to share your screen yeah
yes so it's function vise learning the
main function is learn distribution
which would be mocha Riviere I could now
in the detail make something to learn
distribution from a list of data points
and then you can use admission to do
various things
stress cover the PDF generate a sample
and from this function there will be two
different things
okay so maybe just before I don't know I
mean the order is a good directly okay I
mean distribution we buy it for ages so
the side to the side thing that I want
to talk right now because otherwise we
might forget it's how we get information
from arbitrary machine learning models
right by the way this information
function sushma maybe maybe you know
what's happened with this there was this
initiative to merge a bunch of these
information functions what has happened
to that it is still owned RQ it's not
just um we don't have anyone to work on
it right now I thought if I was working
no it is not we need to get somebody to
work on I mean yes the savior's project
we are trying to figure it out who will
take it we can all start
putting up values for information I mean
I don't know how difficult it is meant
so Sushma is there a clear list of what
needs to be implemented yes we have a
list of things which are already
implemented and things which we want to
implement to make it like a finished
product but is it difficult or is it
mostly just essentially plumbing I think
Nick got it no I mean I don't think so
it's difficult I just think we need
someone to actually spend some time
working on it but if if it's like a
Tiant said we can have multiple people
add their own things to it I mean like
has enough value I can yeah it's really
agreeing on a style right yeah I mean I
would vote for using you know the same
style as what classify information as
now we have a nice
it's called information panel that is in
general utilities that everybody can use
to do the sort of things easily so fine
we're gonna do that those things that
say 126 point examples per millisecond
that's really kind of goofy we should
remove those trailing points what I mean
oh is this born oh yes this one yes it's
true I mean we should get we should make
sure that the number format and stuff is
set to not on a similar function but I
had to code something to make it human
readable you know to figure out you know
if it's say Minister gran Instagram in
whatever you know basically all these
things you know let's say I think we
need a function there's a unit convert
function which defaults to you know si I
suspect we need a function which does
what wolf malphur does which is to
produce the most reasonable form of the
units yes yes right now okay but maybe
you could check that say I mean that's
also a michael type thing I mean it
should be some kind of unit normalize or
some such other
function simplify maybe its unit
simplify okay
so about this for sure for 12 I want to
use information because I don't want to
add right illumination all right so
let's the learning functions at least to
not have any more classifier information
exactly
sorry one design issue is that currently
information also gives you information
about a symbol even if this symbol is a
definition right I mean when you do
information about sign right no problem
but this is no differential I mean
there's no own value sorry and there's
no own value so that's all fine but if I
put you know classifier equal again like
it has a whole first attribute on
information which is probably exactly
exactly the information of si will tell
me si equal because if you are function
like it would kind of over overrides
what does it do if you say information
of f of X so f of 1 when F of 1 has a
value does it deal with that in any
sensible way yeah it's not a symbol over
its companion so actually yeah well so
there's an easy compatibility hack here
which is just to say make it be a hold
first and have it look and see if it's a
symbol
I mean I'm not sure whether we want to
continue I'm not sure anybody's using
that behavior but we could certainly
continue that behavior and have it
yeah a test if it corresponds to one of
the special case so it would evaluate
see if it's a learn distribution or the
classifier yeah that's pretty and if
it's not give information about the
symbol that's horrifying didn't we have
a we talked about this in the design of
the information function did we not
I mean you know it's conceivable as a
design hack we could have an info
function since in the last 30 years the
word info has become a bit more common
than it was 30 years ago when it had to
be called information and we could then
just you know have that work the way we
want it to work
alternatively we have to break
compatibility which I don't want to do
with this information away although
nobody kind of depended on it for
programmatic purposes because it's yes
but it's returning is pure print form
yeah in fact even that print form has
changed over the years um so look
Sushma Kim can you get it sounds to me
like it needs another meeting although
maybe without me to go over what we can
do with this
you know the possibilities are in terms
of that design glitch if we have to we
might have a thing called info I would
prefer to be able to use information but
we may have a compatibility issue that
mm-hmm all right in terms of the yeah I
mean I'm not wild about you know the way
that thing says classifier information
in big bold letters at the top it's not
clear that that's the right graphic
design and I wouldn't mind looking at
that again but the rest of it seems fine
notwithstanding my comment about those
trailing periods and things yes um okay
so let's move on here so you've got this
by the way I wouldn't call it
distribution information I would call it
learned distribution information in the
header of that information block yep
okay all right okay wait for information
okay let's go to the meat of the meeting
all right so--okay division we could
have if we want built-in distribution as
well so we could learn distribution is a
very weird thing to say it's like I mean
it's not obvious that that it's true
actually it could work just with learned
distribution and it will evaluate into
another land distribution dies yeah or
it doesn't need even need to do that I
mean it could just yes it could evaluate
I think it's a better way to do it I
don't think maybe it was a courtesy we
can make learn distribution work with
with image string but I wouldn't do it
in general yeah I also think that's
going to you know end up being pretty
funky because you know like the space of
all possible images who knows you know
if you live on Neptune it'll be very
different you know it's like if you live
underwater
I mean I don't know quite what that
means I think yeah yeah so you know a
little bit like net model I can imagine
that we could have a bunch of
distributions that are built in
distributions
so arguably the way we should do it is
that learned distribution should be able
to take things well it's interesting
that model is something where we where
we're taking you know I mean the
question is where will be our repository
of distributions do we think we're going
to end up with a repository of
distributions well and first I would
imagine just documenting it in the in
the like we did for classify yes then if
it get big we have one page for each if
it get huge get a repository I don't
know well but the question is do we want
something where we can you know is there
other distributions that we're going to
be sort of arriving week by week that
it's useful for us to be able to add to
something I don't think so I mean why do
you say that I mean it seems like a
distribution yeah yeah you kind of right
it's true that there's a lot of activity
there well and also also for us I mean
we've got lots of training sets and it's
like okay you know let's have aerial
photographs
let's have um you know some category you
know we probably got the training data
to Train it
mmm-hmm now to what extent when we're
using I mean are we using these as
priors for other things these learned
distributions presumably we are there
could be yes okay fine
but anyway let's take a look okay so
those are our methods is that right yeah
that's our two methods and what's the
default well it depends on the it will
it will use the same automation as used
for classify as classified as can you
show me an example like can you learn a
distribution of cats cat images okay let
me sir I have to probably get back to a
commit that is dissents because this was
let's see OOP I mean this I think I was
in the middle of changing stuff and okay
let's stash that and whatever
distribution
and let's go back to let's
so
where is it I mean supervised learning
twelve will be fine
yes so we have to put for the VPN
you
okay that should be a working one and
what what could I so just just say
random you know yeah I mean he said over
but but I could I could just do really
okay I could do madness do amnesty and
450 there's not many method at the
moment but I'm going to grab any can do
just a meaty no more resource data
analysts okay fine
an example first have to load the branch
when you branch hopefully well you know
what I just X is going Evan point three
because this one is like a let's just go
there
there you go by the way why does it say
importing the resource content that you
just say input resource content that's a
search merci what's going on
yes just add that ready okay
selection stuff so this is working now
yeah I think it's real so I would say
around some nice things you have to take
all its take yeah yeah exactly little
random sample of let's say 10,000 up
some pole and I remove the tag yep now
you have and I think okay and if I do
will learn distribution on the sample I
hope it is very idea with banana okay
maybe this branch
so great after all learning curve going
on and okay it's using you know what let
me just usability I think it's because
it's trying a bunch of method is really
the best table yeah so I'm going to just
say use a multi no more and it will
still optimize some hyper parameters so
something is
we're here went to zero okay
commercial what happened but English and
then it's meeting almost it's not going
to be a great thing but I can do some
random riots so this hopefully a Goshen
can be I mean yeah I can do like some
sort of digits and but you know even
such a naive method like that is good
enough to distinguish you know like fast
the PDF is good enough to distinguish
Normandy so if I if I take okay this is
a training set so I should really okay
it's a bit cheating but actually it's
pretty happy hundred fifty-eight during
in the PDF
wasn't it normalized it's it's it's a
numerical space so it's not between zero
and one right
this can be especially for eye dimension
which by the way will lead me to anyway
also design proposal the PDF can be
arbitrary high or low and often very low
so which actually gets a sample from the
tests like a delta function I mean the
10 to 58 is like the the numerical value
of some piece of a delta function in
this giant space putting a PDF look put
in a picture of an elephant or something
there in the second argument and let's
see whether it still says to n to the 58
just say picture of an elephant and in
the language it's easy enough to do just
to control equals picture of a picture
of whatever you want
all right
you don't need to press the checkmark
we'll just default but it's more
beautiful of you okay there's an
elephant now let's put the elephant in
okay that's encouraging
why don't you black-and-white if I the
elephant just say yeah just say binarize
or something in front of it
you
cool friends yeah that elephant is not a
digit it's not exactly so I mean that's
why even with the stupid you know method
it's already quite good to distinguish I
know melis I mean yeah so Tolan O'Malley
is gonna be bad but you know there are
better methods that are for images like
real MVP yes I can yes well okay I mean
yes yes yes we are implemented a new
network seeing that that can be quite
better but what we are really interested
in is doing knowledge transfer in a same
way we do for classifying predict yes
where you extract features which is a
really interesting topic because
extracting features for any distribution
is kind of a different business that
exciting feature for classifying yep for
classified you can extract whatever you
want for any distribution you need to
have something that is reversible and
you need to be able to compute the the
kind of you know volume ratio of density
by this transformation yes and I mean it
could be all the way to be knowledge
transfer by fine-tuning a network of
things like that but we would love if
you could keep the principle of
extracting features and so one of the
project we could do is to learn this
transformation and let's say image net
and there's a technique for that so this
is not very preserving and unfortunately
it's not something that will generate
image as good as it again so you know
it's not state of the art but it allows
us to do a really good feature extractor
and we can just you know any feature we
get we pass it through the pipeline we
just learned this ribbon on top you know
and it should give something better but
I must say that knowledge transfer for
any distribution is quite over in a
research area so you know I'm not sure
let's take a look so your point there is
I mean if we have certain categories
where we can use that just like we have
for images we have a base set of
features you know for I mean images
typically anomalies and images are you
know is there a break in this fence type
thing which is very different from the
from the you know
oh yes that we using another type of
thing right but I mean is it the case
that there's a base distribution so I'm
trying to understand do you imagine that
you start from some basis distribution
which is a distribution of all images
and then you're putting on top of it
images of unbroken fences and broken
fences and so on or mostly in this case
unbroken fence and broken yes so then
but but then what you're describing is
that for certain categories like images
that we would have some Bates a priori
distribution yes that we learnt from you
know our curated you know image
identification set etc etc yeah yeah and
we just like kind of modify distribution
to fit better the data that the user
gave right well yeah it sounds very
sensible even but there's no paper does
that you know
okay so so it's it's quite a while why
do we need okay so this volume
preserving thing is needed to have
jacobians going back and forth
yeah so it's a neural network that is
reversible and that you can compute very
easily the Jacobian I mean 2 determinant
of the Jacobian of the transformation so
you know so you have all the elements to
query the PDF this seems interesting but
let's let's just understand what the use
cases are first and maybe we get basic
versions of those use cases and then
improve them with this kind of
technology and there's a benefit to like
methods like orang repeat that it keeps
really normalized probabilities it won't
keep these huge numbers if you query the
probabilities what does it mean to go I
mean but this is normalized and I mean
if you integrated it over yeah yes
but it will be Morrison I mean you won't
like really hi peeps explain why so that
it's a parametric method and so so it
will interpolate and extrapolate maybe
better than some non parametric but even
some non parametric you can make them
smooth like you know like kernel density
estimation you know I mean the careless
moves so-so
yeah I'm not sure about about this
argument but so wait waiting why tell me
why these numbers are so big here and
tell me why this other method will give
more you know modest numbers no no it
won't give more as number I don't think
that I mean okay this okay okay okay
maybe what any was saying that it will
less of a feat like in that case that
seems to be a clear overfitting which
actually we could try by just this time
I'm going to be sure to separate a test
set and a training set so sorry I say
this first 10,000 to train and up let me
quiet because apparently in my brain has
a bunch of messages
and why did it go down to zero what is
the it's that's an issue on this branch
I think it's thing that I solved in the
brain that I'm currently working on okay
fine I forgot what the issue was but it
was a it was a bug
I mean it's a nice tricky okay why is
there so much noise in the background of
these things since that's the actual
data has that I don't know it's in the
back true this is the causal method the
method is a powerful enough amines just
a normal distribution in dimension 700
but still and it's not powerful enough
to but you think this and whatever this
real
yeah yeah even some kernel density
estimation or other things that will
give nice so of those methods we've
listed which ones are currently
implemented this is done this is kind of
done the way to kind of to finish it
channel density Amir can tell more like
I don't think it's finished right it is
kind of finished no get kind of finished
good Gaussian mixture is done as well
nobody's done Whelan VP is we gonna make
it better
yeah almost and made we need to
transform it right it was George's
implementation yes yes but you know the
big part only run on fourth is really
missing yeah like we believe that you
can do room for us in the same way that
we can the focus fan predict before the
distribution okay and the Auto selector
between methods have you figured that
out
yes that's kind of what I was showing
there I mean there's one very
interesting thing which
always yeah okay so to select the best
method is not just looking at the loss
function it's also using as how big is a
model how fast is a model things like
that and it's always tricky to include
in a way the utility of a model given
all these things yep or classify I think
we found kind of a good a good thing
falling distribution it's you know
sometime when the Tribune is learning
you know three values and sometime it's
learning you know I don't know 700
values like here even more yeah yeah and
so as you see when you have 700 values
you know that's a sort of PDF you get so
it's hard to say do I prefer having my
model you know twice better lost
function which basically likelihood on a
test set but on the on the same time 50%
bigger memory I'm a hacker with a wild
call option there is there is there is
so there's goal memory but even with the
performance goal you know we want to be
able to move this sense you know so you
want to have finer control than just
saying optimize for memory not
necessarily finer control I just want
something that makes sense for for users
I won't try to figure out what the
trade-offs are exactly what a trader of
exactly and these needs seen a bit of
work from and think about that look
let's think about that in the you know
ultimately you want to so utility
function for users yeah that is what
and you know that might depend on what
the users are using it for that might
depend on their computers might depend
on a bunch of things but what's the
general theory I mean if a user could
meaningfully define their utility
function and feed it in as a function
for example what will we do with it see
what I'm saying so in other words let's
imagine that a user is that the
performance goal could be you know take
an association which says how much
memory each thing is gonna take how much
this it's gonna take how much that it's
gonna take true to rhythm saying yes yes
actually we have 10 goal already which
is doing 40 seconds you could have
similar things from memory goal or the
most parameterised version would be just
for every candidate method generate an
association that says how much memory
it's gonna take how long it can take etc
and then having a user yeah define a
utility function that says you know I
care now maybe completely unrealistic
for users to define that yeah and then
so then what will happen is we'll end up
with a bunch of named performance goals
yet again which is what we already have
but what you may be saying is that um
you know that we need shades of main
named performance goals a little
different than just optimized for memory
optimized for speed I think this is very
I mean it's not rigorously very hard for
people to express a utility you know in
a mathematical way I feel that poor
abound Aires is the best yeah which is
like Tommy Cole or something yeah I want
I want the the one that I the lowest
lost but he shouldn't be larger than
this amount of memory turned a whole
bird it should be at least this amount
of fast to evaluate I feel like that's a
good idea actually
so exactly yeah it's part of performance
goal so let's imagine that we had
we had a association max time max memory
arrow whatever
to me max sampling time don't go this is
a good idea to do something like this
because you know it could be the case
that the sorry you can't do it with that
performance goal that's in which case it
generates a message and does the best it
can but this is a good idea
you
and I wonder whether that is relevant
for other
no that's probably rel
other functions that use performance
goal as well
I really like this idea actually because
you know max model name arena
Oh whatever here I mean it's gotta be
qualified in some way I don't think it's
just max memory because that's some yeah
you can talk about the training yeah I
like this idea we should pursue this
idea but let's go back to the main main
discussion actually just to give you an
idea that that's the sort of thing that
we measure that was the best information
about the best model that's kind of
verified that showed you know I'm not
seeing it
this is inside a classifier I mean
whatever model you can do and there's a
training information and then you kind
of show all the configuration that I've
been tested so here it's all the same
method McKee normal got a different
value for intrinsic dimension and that's
really interesting and so we can have a
look at the history of everything well
it's the model utility got such a weird
what was that what's what's happening
there the model utility well what was
our big space in that column well this I
don't know what the study is doing here
I've no I know it's it's must be the it
looks dotty so just yeah I think so
display problem because I think it's
just well I think that's for you to try
and track down yeah um okay but anyway
so alright yeah that's very nice okay
let's let's go back to the main thread
here because I want to get to anomaly
detector yes yes yes okay so you have
any solution and then I'm strongly
suggesting that this learned
distribution thing that we try and train
it on some things like images aerial
photographs whatever else mm-hmm which
shouldn't be very difficult to do I mean
we have those training sets
yeah yeah and it's named distributions
learned and which actually will overlap
with named detective named missing in
pewter yes exactly
okay so let's keep good so okay PDF same
as what PDF is doing now except you
cannot do with symbolic evaluation means
simply yes we could probably introduce a
long PDF because as you just so right
now 10 to the 58 10 to the minus 281 and
I'm really image is going to be worse
than that so log PDF would make sense
why don't you just say log of the PDF
because of the precision issue I mean it
mean to say that that will actually run
out of machine precision bits yes yes so
it could return in arbitrary precision I
think it should decision why not do that
yeah yeah I think that's better idea I
mean unless we think I mean these
numbers are pretty non meaningful anyway
you you should talk to Roger about log
PDF I I don't think it's great I think
unless he thinks there's some other
reason in the world of statistics to
have a log PDF I would say us we don't
do it ok um where we we just don't
document it well you can put it in some
hidden context somewhere yeah okay
random variate yeah run Barry 8 ok so to
get a new example it's exactly the same
as the current in the mariette great
this optional maybe I took after
so alright so the goal here and we
ticked off for arbitrary anomalies so we
kind of you know no explicit information
at least about what anomalies are so
it's purely unsurprised although you
might have a prior distribution well not
of the anomalies but but these
distribution of what the normal behavior
is exactly exactly that's the thing that
you learn from from the data so so
learn that sweater stuff rights learn
distribution from the normal data okay
very important Alex Lee okay we're gonna
talk about it's just afterward and then
to tell that something is an anomaly you
compute its PDF and then you look in
which percentile this PDS PDF Falls if
the data were normal so so for for the
normal and if it's below a threshold
then it's an anomaly and I mean okay boy
p-values the overuse p-values of medical
research and other content areas right
again it's kind of an extension of the
classic p-value so we have potentially
all the name for its I mean we're gonna
talk about it just after but I mean I
mean the fact is okay so I these just
have a threshold on the PDF right but to
communicate with the user so we're going
to go it just afterward yeah you know so
the user can set the threshold it's not
nice to have a PDF threshold because you
see the kind of value clear gives so
it's better to have a sort of p-value
and if you put something like 0.01 it
means that if the data falls in the
first percentile you know of the less
likely considered anomalous but we're
not sure if we should call it because
p-value I mean actually when we started
designing this with with Aniyah
I don't understand why it's called
evaluation just probability
we could call it probability threshold
as well which seems a lot more easy to
understand but okay okay okay but it's
not the probability to be an anomaly
that's very important now I understand
so probability that you that okay so the
issue is what counts as an anomaly if
the probability that this should happen
is less than 0.01 then consider it an
anomaly right exactly exactly
okay exactly and this may be a bit for
example when you use okay straining
let's go directly to using the detector
you can ask for p-value and these may be
confusing if you ask for the probability
people might say oh there's a 2% of
chance that anomaly which is not true
it's not understand okay so look um what
you are trying to contort
so it's it's if the word normal wasn't
used for a different purpose really what
this is is the probability under normal
conditions under ordinary conditions
that you will get this
yeah yeah exactly and so ya know we
should be like well you know the world
expected probability might be a better
way to
if you call it expected probability
right expected as in expected when you
don't you know anomaly is I don't know
why I'm thinking of that nobody expects
the Spanish Inquisition silly line but
you know an anomaly is what you don't
expect yeah
I mean that okay so why don't you write
that down you know expected probability
threshold
and you're in your list that yeah mmm
yep I mean I'm not sure it's right but
that's a you got what I'm saying cuz
then then what you could say is anomaly
detector blah blah blah expected
probability and expected probability
people won't think that means the
problem is that it is a layered like
it's like a mean for every dt9 oh I know
I know
so that doesn't seem right
someone on the livestream is saying just
call it threshold yeah the problem is
that we have to name this other case
which is extracting from the anomaly
detect exactly what the ordinary
probability is for that situation um
abnormality value no but it's not the
abnormality right right by the way
someone else has stolen the livestream
is it going to be possible to do
stochastic variational inference which I
don't know what it is do you know what
that is I mean this is a high level
automatic function so you'll use methods
that can be you know viable to encoder
actually we have a version of an encoder
but we're not going to use it straight
away because it's not a method you can
compute a PDF in a blink of an eye it's
good and generating though so I guess we
will add them to this list of method
we'll add a bunch like these are kind of
they're good at everything that you can
sample fast you can query the PDF fast
the PDF is exact but then you have this
whole slew of other method where the PDF
is slow to be computed or the sample is
slow to be computed all the PDF is
approximate yes all these sort of things
like you know racing like both real
machines and and even again again you
can generate where the data is fast you
cannot compute the PDF you can just
computer score that is somewhat related
to the PDF also if you are a traveler
and distribution and again generalizes
them I think it just won't be in the
automatic thing so all of these will be
automatic you probably have done that
the user can specify and they will know
that if they use again they won't be
able to get a PDF so that's why we for
the first version we you know just focus
on this one it's easy to make them you
know play nice together in the same
automation procedure right and then
we'll add
kind of the one that need to play on
their own yeah because we can compare ok
what's very important since it can all
can all complete the PDF you can compare
them yes you know compare again with
boss or machine with one of these is
hard
yeah right okay let's keep going here
okay so so we've got a question here
about what we're calling these
thresholds and so on um but let's just
try to understand
anomaly detection of a bunch of examples
gives an anomaly detector but so
I don't understand why there isn't an
anomaly detect where there are a bunch
of samples and then a value
yep so that's the other functions so we
thought about something called deeds
anomalies well that's nice but but I'm
suggesting for your main function
instead of calling it
I mean okay so let's look at the
classify example we've got classify and
we've got classifier function right
making sense yep so why isn't this
anomaly detect an anomaly detector
function
well those the names no that's I mean
yeah yeah yeah could be a good normally
detect there's perfectly fine to say
well here if you say anomaly detect
they're a bunch of examples and then the
second argument could perfectly well be
a bunch of samples and you just say
which of these are anomalies
well I don't know what what does anomaly
detection not I agree I mean this was
kind of to follow the over unsupervised
learning function which was you know
feature extraction dimension reduction
learn distribution because all of the
unsupervised learning of the fact of
these share properties that we can
either learn something or apply to the
data at hand
and see what I mean like like these fine
anomalies will actually or delete
aluminous will actually work under that
are given that we train on the data end
which is actually an interesting problem
because it means that there's a sort of
a chicken and egg thing you know because
we want to learn on normal data but we
don't have access to normal data so the
strategy is to start with a subset of
data that we're quite confident they are
normal and we train on that and then we
add you know in incremental ways as data
point that we think are the most normal
and so it's bit like clustering yeah so
that's kind of why we followed the
detector hold on hold on hold on let's
walk through this moment okay so you
think I mean
I could imagine it's not fast enough
basically to just say anomaly detect of
a thousand things comma one thing for
example okay let's give a crazy case
let's say oh I don't know you're trying
to work out
um
did this person that's a good case
did this person really walk up the
mountain with that pedometer or did they
simply put their pedometer on some
machine okay
and you know it's a one-shot thing
you've got well you know you're not
pre-training you're just saying here are
a thousand cases where we know it was
okay now tell us about this one case
okay that leads to a important thing is
that here we do not explicitly say the
one that we believe okay I understand
the one is just only give the ones that
you believe are okay
sorry oh no wait a minute is it useful
can you learn anomalies better if you
can say these are the ones we think are
okay these the ones we think aren't okay
then it's more likely classifier you
won't look at the one that you think and
not okay you will only look at the one
you're thinking okay but it is useful
because then you don't have the question
should I discard some to train my
distribution you just take all of them
you don't distribution and you're done
so it has some value but one thing that
is important is that we never look at
the anomalies because we assume that the
space of anomalies is so large that we
cannot learn anything from it yeah so
that's something we we we started at
some point some roots let's try to get
some information about their anomalies
and so on and then we figure out it's
classified we all right
[Music]
so you know the claim is the anomalies
are rare and if you learn the you know
if you learn from bunch of examples even
though that might contain some anomalies
you're still asking you know so if the
anomalies were happening 10% of the time
you're it's hopeless
no miss any because we have the strategy
of kind of growing by starting with the
you know they ties that is the safest
yeah well that's very I'm saying in the
in the general case if you've got you
know enough data and less than 0.1% of
it as anomalous you just feed the whole
thing and including the anomalies yeah
this will be fine yeah right I think
that will be the most common case here
there's something we to be careful of is
a repetition of an anomaly because
anomalies are very rare but you know for
some reason this you know because
something is wrong something is broken
and starts certainly generating crazy
measurements but it generated the same
few times well so let's look at a use
case that we'll have okay which is
monitoring a bunch of our servers okay
generate a bunch of stuff generate log
files all these kinds of things we
pretty much know things are not you know
we know what it means to be operating
nominally so to speak
so you know we just won't train it on
things where we know that the whole
thing was broken yes yes although there
will be lots of ups and downs
even as we you know okay but let's let's
keep going and actually okay okay very
related there's an option we were
thinking of putting which is called
anomaly either anybody frequency and
Emily fractional don't have an idea but
basically it's a user that estimates the
frequency of anomalies in the training
data very important they don't say
anything about the test data let's just
say in the data I give you I believe
there's about 1% of anomaly or 0% so
actually the decay is when you put only
good data if we put 0% and it's horrible
to that option what can we do else I'm
not sure I mean these are what will be
an analogous thing
um
gosh the anomaly frequency just suggests
that is the expected I mean what you're
saying there is that's the frequency of
anomalies in the input training data
exactly
let's kill it
keep looking at some other stuff you
have here just understand alright is a
pay threshold then the ID okay when you
detector it would be like classified
true/false except you can as a
probability but you asked some people
you type thing instead these are detail
and then we thought about are you sure
you want true false are you sure we
don't want yeah I guess we need that I
guess we need that because then we can
do a select or not but I mean yeah
exactly and and I mean I'm wondering if
we want a function called anomaly
probability rather than having to ask
for the specifically for the probability
there
it seems like it's a generally useful
thing you know what's the chance that
this is anomalous seems like that's what
people want to ask a lot of the time
they will but we cannot give that we
cannot give that why
because we don't know anything about a
distribution of the anomalies so this
would go back to classify classify can
do that because you give information
about you know Class A and Class B but
here we don't use anything about the
normally so we cannot tell probability
but what the heck is not done this is
the p-value so that's what you were
saying exactly before right if
everything was normal the probability to
have something worse I mean less likely
in this example is I understand but
what's wrong with schooling that anomaly
probability that the probability that
this example is anonymous no no no it's
not it's the probability that in the
ordinary distribution something could
live could be further away than this
exactly exactly
which is not the probability of anomaly
in some ICS the probability of it not
being anomaly it's not even that and
that would be yeah yeah it's you know if
over anomalies leaves very very far in
the PDF then actually even if you have a
p-value of 0.01 the actual probability
of being an animal he is 10 minus 10
because actual anomaly is a period that
is much much much much lower
I didn't quite understand so I see I
mean this there I see I understand the
actual anomaly is a far away but you are
still your
yeah I get it okay let's just let's just
see to the end of your your thing so so
then we'll be late anomalies that's
interesting exactly which basically
would yeah that's interesting and could
be used quite generally and as it is and
we're thinking of the possibility are
the first argument to put anomaly
detector inside or to use it as like one
of the built-in what you're saying that
the normal cases that's just data there
and it and the anomalies you know and
applied on the other in the other case I
mean that could be an option for the
anomaly detector yeah but it's kind of
an external it's a little weird that
there's a two argument thing there
you can't call it a nominal and real
thing it's right now the function yes
yes yes if it's a function as we said
before
there should be function of course I
think so
and yeah okay could be actually actually
this is very interesting because for
classify and predict you might want to
have a memory detector yes you know also
what exactly would you do with it
returned maybe two anomalies when you do
classify and you put you know that's a
classic thing right that you actually
been asking for a while if I do
something like that right because
there's no anomaly detector it will it
could winter would you like that to
return I mean the simple solution will
be in the terminate or missing - yeah I
mean anomalous - kind of a strange it's
it's probably not a language I mean
missing not recognized would be a better
I mean it would be more user sort of
oriented yeah I will be one word I will
be able to camel yeah not recognized I
think that would be the better thing yes
nice yeah and and I guess we could you
know by default actually when we a
visitor normally all classify will train
very naive anim detector and then
probably be conservative right because
if you don't want to classify that
actually we should need something to
inhibit this
if probably a way to change the
threshold actually we'd probably change
the O which also makes em have a
consequent which probably put anomaly in
the name because putting something like
P very fresh whole year it's quite
obscure in the context of class tonight
obscure so it would be a no - okay sorry
let's go back here um I don't even know
what anomaly I mean I don't know what
that well it would be probably anomaly
detection threshold would be a more
reasonable term
[Music]
normally yeah allowing the
identification threshold possibly and
and I guess we so we should use the same
for here wait a minute what is that
that's no no no no that that's a
functional sorry sorry sorry frequency
sorry I'm put at the wrong place here
yes so what would it be anomaly I think
that would be look that would be so
first of all I'm suggesting that
function is anomaly detect not anomaly
detected yeah actually we can because
yeah because I've I mean we thought
about doing an immune attack but
probably doing a fine anomalies is
better because you know what won't have
something that gives positions you know
this sort of stuff so instead of doing
money position you know fine anomalies
daily I mean maybe we thought we just
put a fan anomaly and some property yeah
possible and it could be replaced by a
anomaly detector as well but we are
quite I mean
solution with the delete anomalies and
just a family that is a bit it's a
one-shot function that is you know Swiss
Army the only family one-shot function
and this is justice audience hi so what
do you suggest with respect to anomaly
detection I think that's fine to change
in an immediate act if we think it's
better I mean what it would be more
compatible with like dimension reduction
that returns a dimension reducer
function animation reduce which only
return the reduced vector we would have
anomaly detection which was known as a
function and anomaly detect which
returns there are normal ease if I for
example returns the point is that
anomaly detect could have a two argument
form which actually does the anomaly
thinking just like classify has a two
argument form that actually does the
classification although I'm saying we
never use it to argument form in
retrospect I would have been you know
like if classifier was a classification
wouldn't be that bad
fair enough maybe this should stay as a
normal detection I'm not sure listen
we're running out of time here
um this probably should have been a long
the meeting
[Music]
what is the generate new example state
to generate data synthesize why is that
different from learn distribution and
then well okay so when decision is kind
of a generic function but let's say
somebody just want to generate data they
use data generate thatis in size or
whatever name we call it and then we can
species already grabbed the method that
I good at that for example again yes I
understand but that's something like you
know dream an image type thing it's not
right it's sorry dream and yes exactly
exactly exactly but you might need a
seed for that I mean
another thing you may like to condition
to oblige yes yes yes yes yes
this is getting yeah this asking Mook
about a design and about what the future
of predict may predict can
and this is a whole realm of conditional
distribution so here we kind of limit
ourselves to non conditioned right but
we could imagine this whole thing to
have some condition so here we put learn
distribution cat right
oopsie and so on and yeah I should
discuss this another time the this is
anything is a territory there's some
design that fits well with this current
design right okay help me pick this up
again like tomorrow
ish I mean we've got some momentum here
let's let's try to get this finished I
don't think well I don't know let's
start Erik figure that out okay I I
don't know okay I'm pretty busy right
but yeah
okay